bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo compagnie d'emmanuel
kessler bonjour emmanuel nous voici donc
parti pour un nouveau tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine marquée notamment par les
primaires socialistes qui se dessine le
bureau national cette semaine à avancer
un calendrier des candidatures en juin
ou juillet 2011
un vote des sympathisants en octobre des
échéances qui pourraient rendre possible
une candidature de dominique
strauss-kahn à un micmac au sénat lors
du débat sur la création du défenseur
des droits les sénateurs ont d'abord
décidé de sauver l'indépendance du poste
du médiatique défenseur des enfants mais
devant l'assistance de michèle alliot
marie ont finalement fait marche arrière
le texte va maintenant passer devant les
députés
enfin le député ump gilles carez n'aura
pas gagné en popularité cette semaine il
a demandé presque le doublement du prix
des pv de stationnement qui alimente le
budget des communes la hausse pourrait
se faire mais pas aussi élevée est avec
nous pour commenter cette actualité
christophe caresche bonjour un député
socialiste de paris votre ancrage
politique s'est fait vraiment dans la
capitale aux côtés de daniel vaillant de
bertrand delanoë vous avez été
conseiller régional conseiller de paris
mais depuis 2008 vous respecter une
règle qui fait couler beaucoup d'encre
et de salive en ce moment au parti
socialiste le cumul le non cumul des
mandats
volontairement ou malgré vous alors
volontairement volontairement je ne me
suis pas représenté aux élections
municipales
d'abord il j'éprouve une certaine
lassitude par rapport j'ai fait deux
mandats de conseillers de paris j'ai été
l'adjoint de bertrand delanoë l'adjoint
daniel vaillant et moi je voulais avoir
un peu plus de temps pour me consacrer à
mon travail de parlementaire parce que
ça m'intéresse
et pour cela il faut du temps ouais
avancer la chaudière
il peut leur dire quand même vous avez
fait partie de cette brochette de
politiques qui ont endossé en plus de
leur mandat politique la fonction le
métier d'avocat
oui je
je suis aussi avocat depuis comme ça
c'est à un cumul malgré tout oui on peut
le dire comme ça mais vous savez le
mandat parlementaire n'est pas un métier
c'est une
c'est une fonction avec une indemnité
par un salaire et je trouve que c'est
bien que les politiques gardent un pied
dans la vie professionnelle
ça je pense que c'est autant je suis
pour que l'on mette fin au cumul des
mandats par le mandat unique à
l'assemblée autant on en reparlera
autant je suis pour que l'on puisse
aussi avoir cette expérience
professionnelle alors à l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes beaucoup intéressé
aux questions de sécurité aux droits des
immigrés mais votre dada aujourd'hui ce
serait plutôt l'écologie depuis le
dernier congrès du ps vous a présenté
une motion pour constituer dans le parti
un pôle écologique un ps qui on le verra
lorgne vraiment maintenant c'est normal
du côté de 2012 s'il ya des primaires
qui choisiriez vous aujourd'hui
le problème c'est qu'on ne connaît pas
les candidats c'est difficile moi je
vais vous dire je souhaiterais qu'il y
ait une candidature qui incarne ma
génération je souhaiterais vraiment que
parmi les quatre ou cinq voix les noms
aujourd'hui manuel valls arnaud
montebourg benoît hamon
vincent peillon pierre moscovici bon
voila j'aimerais vraiment que figure
dans cette primaire un de ceux là
je pense que ce serait ce serait utile
au débat je pense qu'on apporte quelque
chose mais je suis de cette génération
de élu en 1990 sont la génération 90
elle est un petit peu voilà on a on a on
a quand même beaucoup eu des
responsabilités locales nationales etc
je pensais pas on a une sensibilité qui
peut être intéressant mais il faudrait
pour cela que ces gens là s'entendent
donc je suggère qu'il passe un pacte de
la jeune génération pour que l'on puisse
le pacte des seniors d'un côté je pense
qu'il faut un pacte d ide les jeunes des
jeunes sont plus très jeunes maintenant
d'ailleurs mais des cadres à ou des
quinquas non mais je lance cette idée je
crois être assez proches des uns et des
autres je les connais bien et je me
désole de voir que
et on n'arrive pas à construire quelque
chose de collectif et je pense que si on
ne construit pas quelque chose de
collectif
cette génération elle aura peu de chance
de peser dans le débat
montebourg peillon valls et cetera il
passe un pacte un pacte entre eux pour
qu on essaye de dégager une candidature
celui qui rassemble plus par exemple
l'impact d'avant primaire un pack
d'avants primaire puisque j'entends dire
qu'il ya un pacte oui entre on y
reviendra
les vaccins me disent de liège on
commence avec une autre actualité un
dossier lourd l'actualité internationale
lundi le raid meurtrier contre une
flotte humanitaire au large de gaza
l'intervention donc s'est déroulée en
pleine mer dans les eaux internationales
six navires à vocation humanitaire mais
aussi politique puisqu'il s'agissait de
dénoncer le blocus de gaza ont été
stoppés par l'armée israélienne dans des
conditions particulièrement violente
le bilan est lourd neufs morts plusieurs
dizaines de blessés à bord d'un cargo
turc le film des événements les
premières réactions de cette semaine
avec mathilde terrier et à l'aube dans
les eaux internationales
les commandos israéliens prennent
d'assaut cette flottille humanitaire à
son bord une centaine de militants
pro-palestiniens direction gaza l'armée
israélienne reconnaît au moins dix morts
ce soir on ne sait toujours pas ce qu'il
s'est passé sur ce bateau l'armée
israélienne at elle ouvert le feu à
distance ou comme le justifie la marine
israélienne des militants
pro-palestiniens et ils armés et
violents
la responsabilité incombe entièrement à
leur gagner aux organisateurs de cette
opération qui n'était pas une opération
de paix mais une opération de violence
et de confrontations depuis 2007 gaza
est soumis à un blocus strict par israël
ce bateau transportait dix mille tonnes
dead essentiellement de la nourriture et
des médicaments
à la mi-journée benyamin netanyahu
assure son soutien total à son armée la
communauté internationale elle dans son
ensemble condamne ce comportement
une indignation que partage le
gouvernement
un incident clichés déroulé de façon et
si la supporter dans les halls
international ressentir vraiment il faut
qu'on attendait d'êta il met notre
condamnation a été fermé de son côté le
hamas a décrété trois jours de deuil en
territoire palestinien et appelle à un
mouvement de grève générale demain est
ce qu on ne réagit pas aussi trop
rapidement dans la communauté atteint
sial quand on a entendu les
condamnations d'israël mais qu'on voit
aussi que ce bateau était affrété par
une organisation quand même proche du
hamas en turquie - st soins quand même
assez clair l'intervention a eu lieu
d'ailleurs dans l'est dans les eaux
internationales et non territoriale et
même même sur le plan du droit
international ne sait pas très bien
quelle est la validité d'une enquête
internationale
oui bien sûr on discute donc donc c'est
une faut que cette enquête ait lieu il
faut qu'israël accepte premier point
israël pourra peut enquêter lui-même et
on voit que dans la presse israélienne
ya beaucoup de révélations elle beaucoup
de critiques aussi sur la face mais
israël est un pays démocratique tout à
fait respectable mais je pense que il
est bien aussi que la la la la
communauté internationale puisse
participer à cette enquête c'est une
forme ou sous une autre
en tous les cas qu'on ait des garanties
d'une objectivité totale dans l' enquête
mais au-delà de cela ce qui est posé
c'est la politique d'israël par rapport
à gaza notamment moi j'ai été en israël
il ya deux ans j'ai bien compris ce qui
se passait vraiment gêné j'ai eu le
sentiment finalement le gouvernement
israélien
finalement considérer qu'il n'y pas de
solution et que il avait décidé
finalement de laisser pourrir la
situation et depuis maintenant des
années on voit effectivement une
situation qui pourrit et la
responsabilité en incombe seulement il
serait non parce que je pense que les
palestiniens ont eu leur part de
responsabilité ils ont eu aussi des
occasions qu'ils n'ont pas saisi il ya
eu le problème de la corruption par
exemple beaucoup pesé sur la manière
dont l'état palestinien s'est constitué
mais je crois que la position d'israël
n'est pas tenable
elle ne l'était pas il ya deux ans il a
encore moins aujourd'hui ont d'ailleurs
décidé de relâcher un peu l'embargo
notamment par mer ce contrôle
international
on peut pas laisser une partie de ce
territoire comme ça à l'abandon
enfin c'est pas tenable surtout qu'ils
aient un contraste absolument formidable
entre ce qui se passe à gaza et ce qui
se passe en israël avec un pays qui
connaît 5 à 6 % de croissance par an il
ya une explosion sur le plan économique
n'est pas tenable donc ce que je je je
souhaite et sur ce plan là peut-être que
cet événement tout à fait malheureux
peut-être aidé c'est que je sais ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'israël change de
politique s'occupe de cette question
aide à un traitement de cette question
et qu'on trouve une porte de sortie et
un règlement qui soient satisfaisants
voilà allez on va passer à la journée du
mardi maintenant avec un parti
socialiste qui décident ces primaires
alors on ce mardi on a effectivement une
idée plus précise du des primaires du
parti socialiste pour les
présidentielles
à l'issue du bureau national le
calendrier est donnée était 2011 pour le
dépôt des candidatures octobre 2011 pour
le vote des sympathisants
alors que semble se dessiner on le
disait tout à l'heure une sorte
d'entente cordiale d'avant primaire
entre dominique strauss kahn martine
aubry et peut-être même ségolène royal
explications de cigares ibanez durant
trois heures les dirigeants socialistes
ont planché sur la copie d'arnaud
montebourg
le rapport du député de saône et loire
prévoit des primaires ouvertes à
l'ensemble des sympathisants de gauche
avec un vote à l'automne 2011
c'est une révolution politique qui
commence en france et vous verrez que
elle est irrésistible des millions de
français vont pouvoir
écrire une page d'histoire de france
avec lui et pour écrire cette page les
candidats seront peut-être moins
nombreux que prévu
martine aubry et dominique strauss kahn
pourrait s'être déjà mis d'accord pour
une seule candidature entre eux
nouveauté ségolène royal semble les
avoir rejoints dans ce pacte implicite
françois hollande candidat déclaré
dénonce des petits arrangements de
circonstance s'agit pas de faire une
compétition simplement pour départager
je ne sais qu'ils s'agit de choisir le
prochain président la réplique c'est
suffisamment importants pour qu'on évite
je crois les petits arrangements les
calculs les calendriers de convenance
les primaires ça n'est pas pour ratifier
un pacte entre les anciens ministres de
lionel jospin c'est pour désigner un
candidat et créer une espérance pour
à droite on ironise déjà sur ses
premiers points d'achoppement quand on
parle de primaire moi je me sens ramené
à l'air le dirait du même nom je crois
que effectivement ils ont un problème
ils ont le trop plein de candidats à eux
de le choisir
c'est leur affaire et puis les français
jugeront désormais les prétendants
socialistes ont jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour se déclarer
la compétition interne s'achèvera six
mois avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle alors christophe caresche
j'en ai entendu un de montebourg qui
parle de révolution il ya quelque chose
qu'on couvre peut-être pas très bien
sexy entente préalable entre les gros
candidats poids lourds pourquoi y at il
besoin de primaires arnaud montebourg
parlé du processus lui-même et c'est
vrai que c'est une réduction de
l'organisation des primaires du fait que
le parti socialiste ait décidé de mettre
en place un processus de ce type est
d'ailleurs arnaud montebourg il faut
vraiment lui rendre hommage parce que
c'est en particulier lui qui s'est battu
au sein du parti socialiste pour obtenir
ce processus il faut savoir qu'il ya
quelques mois la plupart des dirigeants
socialistes étaient extrêmement
sceptique sur sur ce sur ce dispositif
mais alors répondu à ma question
apparemment si tout est joué d'avancé à
6 1 a fait longtemps qu'ils sautaient
avant à quoi vont servir les relations
message à tous
moss pas avant personne ne dispose pas
quand même plus ou moins élevés entendre
n'attendez le pacte auquel certains
s'expriment d'autres s'expriment pas moi
j'étais pas là je sais pas s'il n'y a
pas tout pas peu importe ce qui est vrai
c'est que il faut que les primaires
organise une diversité de candidature et
de position politique c'est pas
simplement d'ailleurs un concours de
beauté
il faut que ce soit un véritable
confrontation sur des positions
politiques c'est comme ça car nos a
conçu ce processus et c'est dans cet
esprit qu'il faut s'y engager moi ça ne
me choque pas par ailleurs qu'un certain
nombre de candidats potentiels putatif
puis se mettre d'accord avant après tout
c'est bien l'esprit aussi des primaires
que de créer du rassemblement et de et
pas simplement d'être une confrontation
fratricide
donc sur ce plan là ça ne me choque pas
mais que d'autres s'organisent pourquoi
pas moi je souhaiterais par exemple
parce que ça c'est encore des rations ce
que vous disiez il ya la jeune
génération mais je vais parler d'autres
choses aussi
je souhaiterais par exemple que les
écologistes viennent dans cette primaire
moi je ils ont pas l'air de le vouloir
mais moi je le souhaiterais je note ce
matin qu'il y à un sondage tout à fait
intéressant c'est ce qu'on va donner les
cif sondage csa donc pour la chaîne
parlementaire qui montre qu'en cas de
primaires voilà c'est pour ça que je
vous interrompez parce qu'on voit les
chiffres c'est plus clair en cas de
primaires aujourd'hui dominique strauss
kahn arriverait largement en tête auprès
des sympathisants socialistes 33 % loin
devant martine aubry 12% ou ségolène
royal
43% des français inscrits sur les listes
électorales sont prêts à participer à
ces primaires 61% des sympathisants de
gauche
alors quelle est votre appréciation sur
ces ce premier indicateur après les
annonces du ps - le chiffre qui m'a
intéressé vous le donnez pas cessé le
nombre de personnes qui se déclarent
prêts à participer et à voter qui est
considérable 71% de la passion mais
c'était pas
et ça c'est très intéressant ça veut
dire noir des électeurs de droite qui
serait bien mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que ces primaires suscite un
intérêt évident donc il faut les réussir
ça peut être un formidable tremplin pour
le candidat qui sera désigné
sur ce plan là encore une fois il faut
que ces primaires organise aux vocations
pour moi à organiser jaillir le paysage
de la gauche la diversité de la gauche
donc on aurait un représentant
écologiste on aurait un représentant
disons 2 2 entre dominique strauss kahn
martine aubry je sais pas enfin bon
ségolène royal etc y aurait un
représentant de la jeune génération y
aurait bon s'est il faut construire une
offre politique qui soit suffisamment
motivante pour que les gens aient envie
de venir et de zim et deuxièmement il
faut aussi penser au rassemblement donc
il faut il faut il faut tenir les deux
bouts de la chaîne
juste un mot sur la question du cumul
des mandats déjà bordée mais vous avez
vu que les sénateurs socialistes sont
opposés à l'application de cette règle
dès 2011 parce qu'il semble ont
l'impression que ça va être un obstacle
pour eux alors que le sénat peut
basculer à gauche est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec absolument pas c'est un
argument que je ne comprends pas on ne
demande pas aux sénateurs socialistes
de qui ce que 13 se représenter et qui
par ailleurs un mandat exécutif dans une
collectivité territoriale de
démissionner avant son élection
c'est pour du tout ça qu'on lui demande
on lui demande simplement de dire à
partir du moment où il sera élu au sénat
comment il entend se mettre en
conformité avec la règle du non cumul et
donc il l'aura il aura après son
élection après son élection la
possibilité de se mettre en ordre par
rapport à ces tribunaux qu il aura eu
l'idée il aura même la possibilité de
garder son mandat de conseiller général
le conseiller régional ou de conseiller
municipal en démission il s'agit
uniquement des exécutifs maire aux
présentes pour cet argument ne tira ne
tient pas et vraiment c'est un marqueur
essentiel pour le parti socialiste cette
question du cumul des mandats je pense
que les français ils sont extrêmement
attachés que c'est un élément de la
rénovation des pratiques politiques qui
est 13 qui sera très important dans
l'élection présidentielle et moi je ne
voudrais pas parce que quelques-uns
évidemment il y sont les plus mal passé
quand même pour en parler puisqu'ils
sont les principaux intéressés
que ce soit au sénat ou à l'assemblée
nationale parce que il ya deux ans sur
concernés qui sont sur un conservatisme
con qu'on loupe 7,7 cet atout face est
bien mardi on va passer à droite
maintenant l'image politique du jour
dominique de villepin qui est en
banlieue l'ancien premier ministre à
moins de trois semaines du lancement de
son nouveau parti de son nouvelle
formation politique s'offre une
immersion très médiatisée avant le
quartier du val fourré dans les yvelines
c'est jérémy afane qui l'a suivi des
dizaines de mains serrées et un accueil
plus que chaleureux
dominique de villepin n'a pas boudé son
plaisir cet après midi son costume
d'opposant à nicolas sarkozy a eu son
petit succès dans les allées du marché
du val fourré écoutez c'est bien de voir
et nombreux titres comme
foulé le sol de mantes la jolie c'est là
que les hommes politiques arrivent ici
concède en plein marché bon
on espère que va découvrir les réalités
réalités de la base
l'ancien premier ministre ne s'en cache
pas il veut incarner une droite plus
sociale et humaine au milieu des jeunes
de banlieue dominique de villepin en
profite pour tacler la politique
sécuritaire du président de la
république qui ne s'est pas rendu dans
les quartiers difficiles depuis
plusieurs mois je regrette que trop
d'hommes politiques parlent dans la
banlieue sans jamais y venir ou alors
derrière des crs les banlieues elles
doivent être vus dans la vie quotidienne
dans ce qu'elle leurs difficultés
quotidiennes et c'est bien ces
témoignages qui nous aide à trouver des
solutions c'est pas la banlieue vu
derrière des écrans de télévision la
banlieue se sont une fois de plus des
hommes des femmes qui ont des rêves
comme tous les rêves et qui demandent
tous chaussés pouvoir les réaliser cet
après midi dominique de villepin avait
tous les attributs d'un candidat en
campagne
mais à quelques jours du lancement de
son mouvement il a une nouvelle fois
laissé planer le doute sur ses
intentions pour l'élection
présidentielle
vous avez entendu tout de même qui se
présente comme une alternative à nicolas
sarkozy est ce que c'est une menace pour
la gauche
non c'est ce que j'appellerais c'est les
primaires à l'ump 1
les primaires un peu sauvage si j'ai
bien compris non c'est pas une menace
pour la gauche je ne pense pas je pense
qu'il incarne une sensibilité à droite
gaulliste chiraquienne et qui a une 1re
substrat qu'à une réalité ça vous étonne
7,7 popularité de dominique de villepin
dans les banlieues c'est pas du tout
l'image qu'on pouvait lui prêter
quelques temps welch et les effets des
cultes et de recettes qu'il a changé
peut-être que les hommes politiques
changent
bon allez voir on passe à la journée de
mercredi est passé mercredi avec des
prunes qui s'annonce plus à l'est alors
le député ump gilles carez bien connu
pour sa loi caresses sur les mètres
carrés a apposé sa se sont non ce mardi
à une peu proposition nettement plus
impopulaire en tant que président du
comité des finances locales
il a demandé le presque doublement du
prix des pv de stationnement de 11 à 20
euros
le gouvernement semble intéressé par une
hausse mais moins élevée sans doute ce
tome assouline le montant de l'amendé de
stationnement n'a pas augmenté depuis 24
ans 75 francs à l'époque
11 euros aujourd'hui trop faible juge le
président du comité des finances locales
le député gilles carez selon lui le prix
n'hésite pas les automobilistes à
prendre en tickets comme ça n'est que 11
euros
je fais mon calcul 11 euros pour l'amant
de trois quatre heures de
bar king par exemple au centre de paris
on a tout de suite atteint les 11 euros
donc je cours le risque
or nos centres villes il faut qu'on
arrive à les faire vivre et pour les
faire vivre
il faut garder l'accès automobile mais
il faut qu'une rotation des véhicules
chaque année ces amendes rapportent 600
millions d'euros aux communes la
cagnotte pourrait quasiment doubler mes
problèmes
en période de crise la proposition
divise à droite comme à gauche
c'est une augmentation beaucoup beaucoup
trop importante qui touchera ceux qui
ont besoin de la voiture quotidiennement
et qui vit dément sera particulièrement
lourde pour les plus modestes
je trouve que c'est excessif l'attention
non plus de ne pas avoir un nouveau
prélèvement une hausse d'impôt déguisée
par par cette augmentation la je pense
qu'il ya vraiment d'autres d'autres
façons de faire ça me semble plus être
un rapporteur général du budget qui veut
remplir un peu les caisses que que d'une
démarche environnementale
rien n'est encore décidé mais
actuellement le gouvernement étudie de
près la proposition de gilles carez
alors cette augmentation c'est une bonne
arme pour dissuader les citadines
prendre la voiture c'est un racket
moi j'y suis très favorable je suis
député de paris par ailleurs il est
clair qu'aujourd'hui le montant de
l'amendé n'est absolument pas dissuasif
vraiment ce que les gens qui ont des
jeux sera un peu mal faire il le sera un
peu plus c'est pour ça que faut qu il
faut savoir que la proposition de
monsieur car elle n'arrive pas comme
cela ça fait plusieurs années qu'un
certain nombre d'élus travail sur les
questions ont souhaité une
municipalisation du stationnement dans
toutes ses composantes à la fois
de l'occupation du domaine public mais
aussi la répression et pourquoi parce
que le stationnement est un élément de
la régulation de la voiture dans une
dans une agglomération il est en
particulier dans un centre-ville donc
c'est plus alors c'est ensemble que
buteur c'est un argument écologique
c'est un argument budgétaire car
aujourd'hui les gens qui ne payent pas
l'amande
ils ne payent pas leurs dates enfin les
gens qui par don ne payent pas leurs
dates heures et préfèrent parfois payer
la mort quand il la paye mais ils ne
payent pas leurs dates heures celle
qu'ils ne payent pas l'occupation sur le
domaine public et ça ça rapporte de
l'argent non pas l'état d'ailleurs mais
aux communes
donc ça rapporte à paris ça rapporte de
l'argent au stif pour faire des
transports en commun syndicat des
transports voilà donc moi ce que je
soutient vraiment très fortement cette
proposition simplement je pense qu'elle
devrait on devrait pouvoir les modules
et sur le territoire national c'est dans
une petite ville et de ses dames le trou
alors mettons la a5 entre 5 et 10
bon voilà est-ce que ça va pas
s'inscrire dans une politique plus large
parce qu'on pense à paris notamment
est-ce que ça doit pas s'accompagner de
créations de deux parkings autour de
paris pour pour que les gens puissent
faire ça on le fait
et on sait très bien qu à paris
notamment pour ce qui concerne la zone
centrale ici a pas de mesures de
régulation alors que ce soit la
limitation
c'est ce qu'on fait là juste à ces
barbus que ce soit le stationnement il
vous faut des éléments de régulation
d'accord il faut filer en mp oui tout
est maintenant je suis prêt à signer
avant olalala contre 20 mai même 20 on
avait parlé on a été jusqu'à 30 le le
wec là ça serait vraiment très bien joué
ouais enfin vous savez
regardez un psy vous payer une amende
disons tous les tous les trois jours
au mieux tous les huit jours tous les
dix jours passent même de 25 euros
parce que les contractuels passe pas
évidemment on passe parfois entre les
mailles du filet que les cieux mercredi
une revenante dans l'actualité on va
encore parler de fiscalité la taxe
carbone la france a dû y renoncer elle
fait son retour via une proposition de
la commission de bruxelles qui suggère
de l'appliquer au niveau européen comme
le voulait d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy
cette taxe carbone new look rapporterait
au niveau européen 300 milliards d'euros
par an jérémy hartmann d'abord un prix
plancher 20 euros la tonne de co2
ensuite des secteurs visés les
transports le bâtiment et l'agriculture
mais pour l'instant les contours de
cette taxe carbone européenne sont
encore floues la commission européenne
basse son projet sur un document interne
loin d'être définitif
moi je vous dis la taxe carbone
européenne 1
on en parlait beaucoup on aime être en
france maintenant ça va être au niveau
européen vous allez voir on va en parler
longtemps longtemps longtemps mais a
tellement des intérêts des intérêts et
bien qu'on ne mettra pas le dispositif
est sensible politiquement et l'union
européenne avance à pas feutrés sur le
sujet car il faudra que cette taxe
carbone soit adopté à l'unanimité des
pays membres
première piste envisagée la nouvelle
fiscalité verte se ferait en deux volets
une taxe en fonction des émissions de
co2 une autre en fonction de
l'efficacité énergétique des produits
dans cette hypothèse les biocarburants
seraient les moins taxés le charbon lui
verrait son coût augmenter pour devenir
dissuasif
pas de quoi rassurer certains pays comme
la pologne ou l'allemagne
encore très dépendant de cette énergie
est simplement deux points il faut
absolument traité 1
la coordination européenne qui était
indispensable dans ce domaine et il est
bien qu'il ait une proposition
européenne sur le sujet 2
de mon point de vue la taxe carbone
c'est un élément parmi d'autres de la
fiscalité écologique il faut expliquer
partager avec les français les européens
ce qu'est la fiscalité écologique on
peut pas faire une taxe carbone comme ça
tout seul dans son coin
la taxe carbone version européenne
pourrait être mise en place à partir de
2013 et entrer en vigueur
progressivement chaque état restera
libre d'utiliser cet argent comme bon
lui semble par exemple en reversant des
compensations à certains contribuables
alors christophe caresche quand il
débarque chez nous faut bien dire que
cette taxe carbone était très
impopulaire est ce qu'elle sera moins
impopulaire dès lors que ce sera
bruxelles qui l'imposera faudra
l'expliquer
le problème c'est que je crois que c'est
très difficile d'envisager la fiscalité
écologique de manière séparée du reste
de la fiscalité
c'est pour ça que moi je plaide
notamment si la gauche revient au
pouvoir pour le fait qu' on puisse
intégrer dans une réforme globale de la
fiscalité qui par ailleurs se pose un
volet écologique et notamment la mise en
place d'une taxe carbone c'est être
réservé sur la proposition européenne
ont alors la proposition européenne
elle est très intéressante elle n'est
pas très intéressante d'ailleurs
forcément par rapport à la france elle
est très intéressant par rapport aux
autres pays qui ne sont pas dans
l'europe notamment par rapport à la
chine ou aux pays émergents moi je suis
convaincu qu'aujourd'hui les
négociations sur le climat sont bloqués
par rapport aux mécanismes qui a été
choisi de quotas d'émission enfin je
veux pas rentrer dans le détail les
industries polluantes peut pas si on est
dos à polluer bloquer cette situation il
faut donner un prix au carbone au niveau
mondial je crois que la chine c'est que
j'ai cru comprendre était était
intéressé par cette sixième ronde dans
le jeu d'une plus grande vertu elle rend
quand j'ai l'air géologie taxe carbone
qui concerne les produits qui la
concerne et je crois que derrière
l'initiative européenne il y à cet enjeu
international et mondiale pour ça que ça
peut avoir un effet d'entraînement
bien sûr c'est ce qui peut permettre ce
serait une revanche après l'échec de
renault c'est peut-être une autre voie
que celle de copenhague c'est à dire de
déplacer un peu les choses on est plus
encore une fois dans un échalas échanges
de quotas d'émissions où chacun dit moi
je vais consommer tel montant de co2 etc
et maintenant voilà avec un échange les
gars ce n'est qu'à nice est vrai que l
amour de nietzsche et ça ne marche
système du nom d'un autre l'autre
mécanisme qui est de rendre de donner un
prix au carbone au niveau mondial et à
ce moment là évidemment tous les
produits ils seraient assujettis niveau
c'est bien ça va pénaliser les
entreprises européennes dans un énorme
étant justement
justement aujourd'hui vous avez raison
ou l'allemagne la france d'ailleurs je
pense assez ce real c'est contre cette
position sur le parce que évidemment ça
grèverait la compétitivité de
localisation etc
mais si ça s'inscrit dans une
négociation internationale et encore une
fois j'ai cru comprendre que la chine
pouvait avancer là dessus eh bien ça
peut être très positif
voilà donc il faut aussi le voir sous
cet angle là y'a pas simplement un angle
europe france c'est parti socialiste à
l'occasion de ses primaires va devoir un
peu verdir son programme faire des
propositions concrètes sur ses cales
c'est une absolue nécessité
c'est une absolue nécessité pour
l'instant c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
je sonnais ci relier un candidat dans la
primaire écologiste
si on veut que avoir un projet qui soit
sociale écolo puisque c'est l'objectif
il faut qu'on ait d'abord la possibilité
de confronter nos positions
d'abord avec les écologistes a priori
ils ont quand même les écologistes vont
être candidate de toute façon c'est une
erreur et le payeront cher ils le
payeront cher
ils auront les mêmes problèmes qu'ils
ont eu à chaque élection présidentielle
ils feront un mauvais score à l'élection
présentielle pourquoi parce que les gens
choisissent un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle un président de la
république qui choisissent pas une
diversité de leurs à lisbonne qui n'est
pas spécialement envie de concourir sous
le tibet est essentiel aux siens de
rêver leur île en sierra leone coup plus
pour leur cause dans une discussion avec
nous ils obtiendraient sur le fond sans
doute un certain nombre de choses et il
obtiendrait aussi d'aider des lissiers à
l'assemblée nationale
c'était un non mais non mais non parce
que si on leur donne ici qu'à ce député
il faut un vous aideront le deal proposé
daniel cohn bendit qui régissent
mais bien sûr il a complètement raison
allez on passe à la journée du jeudi
quand des élus parisiens se prennent à
rêver d'une candidature de françois
fillon dans la capitale
ils appellent ça le g8 les huit maires
ump de paris se réunit chaque mois il ya
cette occasion cette semaine ils ont
lancé un appel à françois fillon pour
qu'il se porte candidat au plus vite
pour les municipales de 2014 meilleure
façon selon bien sûr de récupérer la
capitale thomas souliers certains lui
prédisent un avenir présidentiel eux le
vois plutôt à la mairie de paris
les élus ump de la capitale lance un
appel à françois fillon il compte sur
lui pour représenter la droite en 2014
et rassembler une famille parisienne
très divisée notre intérêt c'est
d'ouvrir largement les portes de notre
majorité présidentielle mais donc de
notre position municipale à des
personnalités importantes légitime mais
une autre personnalité pourrait
s'inviter dans la course
rachida dati la maire du 7e
arrondissement de paris ne cache pas ses
ambitions à l'heure face à la division
annoncé certains ont déjà la solution
il ya toujours la possibilité de faire
des tickets comme on dit et c'est
peut-être une solution intelligente
en tout cas on a le temps d'y réfléchir
certains élus d'un tandem dati-fillon
pourquoi pas ce serait une une assez
bonne formule pour la gauche cet appel
des élus ump relève du cynisme
certains y voient même un paradoxe ce
fillon c'est le libéralisme assumé
c'est le débat sur les retraites c'est
l'étranglement des collectivités locales
aujourd'hui c'est extraordinaire que des
élus demandent au premier ministre qui
est en train de mettre à genoux
l'ensemble des collectivités locales
françaises pour venir s'occuper de la
plus grosse collectivité locale
française avant 2014
françois fillon aurait les yeux rivés
sur 2012
les élus parisiens lui réservé est une
place au chaos pour les élections
législatives de 2012 d'un françois
fillon la candidature qui peut faire
trembler la gauche à paris honnêtement
je trouve ces discussions sont
totalement prématurée
voilà il ya 2012 il ya encore plus de
quatre ans avant 2014 de mandat est
prématuré pour envisager si un candidat
pour la gauche la gesticulation comme
ceux des militaires mais c'est pour la
gauche aussi après la douche mario
candidature parce que bertrand delanoë a
annoncé qu'il ferait pas de l'e3 et
jeunes en mai mais sa succession n'est
pas ouverte pour autant prématuré là
aussi prématurément alors le premier
ministre a d'autres chats à fouetter
quand même cette semaine notamment
quelques déficit à combler dans une
interview à plusieurs journaux il a
confirmé je cite un coup de rabot de 10%
sur presque toutes les niches fiscales
sauf celles qui favorisent l'emploi
certaines devraient mettre m supprimer
le premier ministre rendra ses premiers
arbitrages fin juillet s'attaquer aux
niches fiscales qui se cacha dans le
monde alors c'est un bon début oui c'est
un doux de toute façon il y à il ya un
problème d'assainissement des finances
publiques
donc ça c'est clair la question savoir
qui on va faire payer
nous on a suggéré un certain nombre de
choses du bouclier fiscal et la ville à
l'alourdissement l'alourdissement des
huiles alourdissement de la fiscalité
sur le patrimoine enfin bourg tout un
impôt et il ya évidemment les niches
fiscales moi ce que je suis très déçu
par l'annoncé de françois fillon car je
trouve que ce n'est pas très courageux
je crois qu'il faudra regarder et niches
fiscales par niches fiscales celles qui
sont pertinentes et celles qui ne le
sont pas
manifestement le gouvernement ne veut
pas faire ce travail pour une raison
simple c'est qu'il a peur de buter
contre un certain nombre de catégories
ou de corps oui mais il annonce surtout
le rabot pour toutes
c'est là c'est celle inverse de ce qu il
faudrait faire il ya un certain nombre
de niches qui sont pertinentes y en a
qui ne le sont pas et puis faut regarder
aussi comment les niches fonctionne moi
je pense qu'il ya trois critères il ya
l'emploi la recherche et l'écologie
voilà si les niches répondent à ces
trois critères là je suggère qu'on les
garde si elles ne répondent pas je suis
je suis le cheveux collés au corps moyen
sûr et beaucoup je crois avec le
grenelle 2
oui mais il ya peut-être des effets à
vous de niches fiscales qui sont anti
écologique il ya près de cinq milliards
d'euros de niches fiscales anticollision
donner une
c'est le fait que le kérosène qui se
rappellent les carburéacteur le
carburant des avions n'est pas soumis à
taxation en france mais il n'est pas
soumis à taxation ailleurs non plus mais
il pourrait l'être
il pourrait même s'il est chez nous on
va se trouver dans un problème de
concurrence là pour les lignes
intérieures il pourra l'être pour les
lignes intérieures
voilà donc voilà une suggestion jeudi
une journée de cafouillage protestation
à gauche
malaise à droite aussi séance haute
tension au sénat autour du projet de loi
qui instaure le nouveau défenseur des
droits dans un premier temps les
sénateurs avaient rejeté la suppression
du défenseur des enfants qui doit en
principe se fondre dans cette nouvelle
institution
mais finalement et sur une pression du
gouvernement une majorité a accepté que
le défenseur des enfants soient
finalement bien chapeauté par le
défenseur des droits
c'est un peu compliqué récit de ces
heures de confusion avec sophie normand
suspension de séance réunion en
commission puis nouveau vote c'est dans
une cacophonie générale que le sénat a
finalement réintégré le défenseur des
enfants dans le périmètre du futur
défenseur des droits
le gouvernement y tenez fortement de
peur de voir sa réforme amputer ce soir
l'opposition a refusé de participer au
vote le parlement est souverain en cette
matière le pouvoir exécutif le méprisent
hier pourtant deux amendements soutenus
par les socialistes les centristes et
quelques sénateurs ump maintiennent
l'indépendance du défenseur des enfants
pour le gouvernement c'est un camouflet
il demande alors une nouvelle
délibération un déjeuner aux prés de
nicolas sarkozy aura eu raison de la
position des centristes
le défenseur des enfants et chats tout
de même à une fusion à la différence de
la halde et du médiateur il sera nommé
par le premier ministre pas sûr que cela
suffise à maintenir sa liberté de parole
le texte doit maintenant être examiné
par les députés alors christophe
caresche que défenseur des enfants soit
inclus dans cette nouvelle autorité est
ce que c'est vraiment un drame côté il
ya beaucoup de confusion autour de ce
texte parce qu'il ya pas que le
défenseur de deux des enfants il ya là
il ya là ses rôles d être la
discrimination commission de déontologie
de la sécurité dans dans la police
thaïlandaise vous faites partie des
représentations a réduit aussi
absolument bon et pourquoi y ait
beaucoup de confusion parce que les des
autorités qui existe déjà et qui font
bien leur travail elles ont le sentiment
elle d'avoir oui mais manquant de la
constitution qui veut rationaliser
social d'annoncer deux mais alors un ces
autorités n'ont jamais été consultés
dans la réflexion sur l'élaboration du
projet de loi
la cnds par exemple n'a jamais été
consulté par personne on n'a pas demandé
son avis ça fait des années qu'elle
travaille sur ces questions elle a quand
même une expérience elle aurait pu la
porter et le deuxième point c'est qu'on
a le sentiment que les garanties
d'indépendance les pouvoirs
d'investigation d'injonction que aura le
nouveau défenseur des droits seront
peut-être inférieur au pouvoir qu
aujourd'hui on sait autorités donc c'est
ça le problème c'est que on a le
sentiment d'un texte qui finalement sous
prétexte essayer de rationaliser et donc
de 20 a fléchi revoir vaches non non non
regardez la cnds sur dix points dans son
dernier rapport a montré que les
garanties données par le nouveau
défenseur des droits seront inférieures
à celles qu'elle donne aujourd'hui dans
l'exercice de la mission sur la
déontologie de la sécurité
donc c'est ça le problème et on a le
sentiment qu'un certain nombre de ces
autorités que ce soit le défenseur des
enfants ou la cndr ça veut dire qu'on
est en difficulté mais qui ont d'énormes
difficultés moi je les mesures au
quotidien notamment avec la hiérarchie
policière avec les syndicats de police
on a le sentiment qu'à l'occasion de ce
projet de loi de cette réforme
on veut tout simplement et tout fait en
partie ces autorités
et voilà le problème journée dans
l'indépendance pour il faut que le
gouvernement donne des gages et des
garanties fortes sur la manière dont le
au défenseur des droits va exercer ses
prérogatives
c'est à cette condition qu'ils sont sûrs
à cette confusion allez toujours au
sénat le porte-parole du gouvernement
luc chatel a ironisé sur martine aubry
après les propos de celle ci sur nicolas
sarkozy et bernard madoff il a fait
allusion au projet socialiste du caire
un mot anglais qui désigne le soin ou
encore le souci aux plus faibles pour
comprendre on écoute luc chatel
martine aubry monsieur le sénateur nous
promettait la société du care la société
de la protection la société du respect
et bien avec l'insultent avec la
provocation
nous ne sommes pas dans la société du
care monsieur le député avec les
vieilles sur le sénateur avec les
vieilles recettes avec les recettes du
passé
je crois que nous sommes plutôt pour la
société de l'antiquaire
au delà du jeu de mots c'est long
c'était drôle aussi
non dans un cas c'est un jeu de mots de
potache et dans l'autre c'est un manque
de respect non pas vis-à-vis de la
personne et la pontiac
sarcastique humoristique dans la
comparaison avec madoff je pense pas que
le président de la république les prix
au premier degré et au pied de la lettre
en tous les cas moi je n'ai pas pris
comme ça note orages l'a mal pris
oui bien sûr mais je pense qu'il a assez
de recul
il a montré dans le passé aussi qu'il
avait une certaine liberté de ton et de
parole et l'archaïsme de martine aubry
ça semble être un axe maintenant de
l'ump et de l'équipe qui entoure nicolas
sarkozy oui bien sûr mais vous savez je
crois que 2010 avait un moment de vérité
et ce qui va primer dans l'élection
présidentielle ça sera l'authenticité
ça sera pas les modernes contre les
anciens ça sera l'authenticité et la
vérité par rapport à une situation quand
même qui est très difficile il va
falloir montrer un chemin aux français
alors vendredi on va se détendre un peu
christophe caresche pour terminer cette
émission va rester t1 dans le registre
de l'humour un apéro seynois et des
couloirs de l'assemblée ou en couleur un
sénateur qui organise un apéro via
facebook et qui plus est en donnant
rendez vous au sénat la plus grande
surprise fut d'ailleurs celle des
huissiers du sénat qui ont entrouvert
les portes aux invités du sénateur
christian de moins que le reportage de
marie brémaud un apéritif alcoolisées au
sénat pour parler du service civique
c'est l'invitation lancée par christian
de minc sur facebook au début de
l'événement ils commencent à s'inquiéter
du pro
des invités à voir des jeunes quoi c'est
ça dont je ferai cela
tarek - oui par rapport aux invitations
mais bon
bonsoir sans robert visiblement cela ne
s'arrange pas l'appel de l'apéro semble
attirer les plus âgés ils ont beau jeu
ou pas
là mais j'ai pas su principal
on est vraiment amusé inusité
quand on questionne les quelques
étudiants présents l'apéritif facebook
dans l'enceinte us est là l'initiative
surprend et séduit sur la baisse
c'est assez étonnant
attendu à une invitation par courrier on
va dire des mots dits communicants nous
l'hôte de la soirée est plus que
satisfait c'est un beau succès et en
plus de la soixante jeunes d'israël
c'est dehors d'un très beau succès 21h
ce qu'on attend mais sous la pluie les
recalés ne partage visiblement pas
l'avis du sénateur
moi je suis avec des candidates une fois
déjà oui alors vous avez ça vous donne
des idées
ça vous inspire se méfier quand même
parce que le résultat est quand même pas
très probant mais c'est vrai qu'il est
sur internet on voit toujours évidemment
les jeunes générations mais il y avait
aussi des décès en plus âgé il ya des
frais décrétés moi je vois pour ce qui
concerne mon parti politique
il ya beaucoup de gens qui écrivent
beaucoup qui ont beaucoup de choses à
dire et il faut du temps pour cela donc
maintenant ils sont ils ont des apéros
cheryl maas midi les apéros il a laissé
nadal et enfin à l'assemblée le temps
des soeurs va on va y réfléchir
l'expérience légèrement quoi ton par le
chiffon dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
pour la séance des questions au
gouvernement cette semaine l'ump jacques
meyer s'était choisi une veste rouge
comme le socialiste patrick roy qui lui
s'en est fait une marque de fabrique
tous les jours psych et échanges devant
la caméra de patrick herman sénat
je suis prudent s'est pas portée dans
cette vente
et non je sais plus quand même il fut
rouge à l'heure des deux qu'il purge lui
c'est bien sûr social-démocrate décadent
on a déjà moi je suis un gaulliste et
depuis vercingétorix je défends la
nation c'est pas par lui la réaction le
plus rouge chez moi en réalité c'est lui
qui plagie la vérité du peuple
et crois votre votre collègue socialiste
obtient toujours une veste rouge
non mais de façon très remarqué dans
l'émission tous les cas il a une veste
qui se remarque pas toujours rouge elle
peut être blanche et peut être verte et
peut être enfin tous les cas si les tons
très criard ça change de la veste au et
en plus il a il a une voix aussi qui
porte beaucoup mieux qu il y avoir une
veste colorée que de la retourner
oui voila voila voila voila merci en
tout cas christophe caresche devenu
participé avec le sourire à cette
émission de parlement hebdo on devrait
se retrouver la semaine prochaine aux
chaînes même lieu même heure
au revoir